plot twists are a thing of beauty you
may understand the story but five
minutes from the end boom Bruce Willis
was a ghost all along he light was blind
all along or worse still Troy and
Gabriella were really brother and sister
all along okay one of those isn't
strictly true but you get what I mean
video games are packed with plot twists
but one twist in particular can make the
gamer feel like the scum of the earth so
here are five times you thought you were
the hero but ended up being the villain
Sal he'll too scared the bejesus out of
me I wish I could say I was a child but
really when I played it I was already a
Hulk in six-foot-three man with the
receding hairline and potentially
diabetic as well but I digress
South Hills who was a fiendishly clever
game it is settled by a letter you
received from your wife oh did I mention
she died three years ago dead person
can't write a letter the letter tells
you to go to your wife's favorite
holiday destination Silent Hill so off
you dropped with your Bryan Adams good
looks and your trusty cagoule nothing in
Silent Hill is how you remember it
everything is rundown decaying foggy and
gray and there's sexy horror pests
everywhere and a pyramid headed man out
for blood
play for a few hours longer and the
twist hits you like a knife to the gut
you murdered your own wife you bastard
you can no longer handle the grief and
your mind is deteriorating before your
eyes so in a messed up where the hero of
the game are those sex dolls that you've
been trying to avoid who'd have thunk it
heavy rain lets you play as a barber
track to serve his son the private
investigator trained to save the other
guy's son a policemen track to save the
other guy's son or a journalist who
wants a scoop for a story but
accidentally has sex with the guy and
now else to save his son are you with me
plot twist one of these is a serial
killer and if you haven't guessed it
it's the mild-mannered man-mountain
Scott Selvi he talked the murder victims
and parents of loved ones so he can
erase anything that would link him with
the murders what a criminal mastermind
we find this out in a chilling scene
where his own brother dies and his
father
adult Scott wants to find a father
capable of saving his son and of course
the right thing to do is to murder a
little boy every week for 30 years it's
really a love story isn't it from the
outside SpecOps is a typical military
shooter where you and your buddies shout
hoorah a lot and kill foreigners in
their own country
things change after a horrible scene
where you murder a ridiculous amount of
civilians with white phosphorus it
forces the player to realize instead of
following orders you should be
questioning them and now look what
you've done you monster walk you have
two options left you either realize and
admit that you are the problem with the
world talking I don't understand what's
he doing time to go home or better than
that you fully embrace your actions and
become the monster you never knew you
were
gentlemen welcome to Dubai
Shadow of the Colossus what a freaking
great game your job is to save a
princess by cutting down large creatures
who are obviously bad guys because
you're only a little boy
it's basically David versus Goliath 16
times it's just an advanced Mario game I
told myself but once again life slaps
you in the face and makes you realize
that you are the real villain what have
I done
it turns out I've just killed endangered
species they're never gonna walk the
planet again what you actually do at
this point in the game is bring the
second coming of a satanic monster oops
let's sweep that under the carpet and
move on quickly we've made it to the top
of the list and it comes from
PlayStation exclusive The Last of Us the
last of us took moral ambiguity to
another level as you've gone a road trip
with snotty nose tea ninja Ellie who is
immune to a zombie outbreak over the
next few weeks and months you start to
like her and you become a father and
daughter team who lovingly murder people
and look at pornography together early
that ain't for kids get rid of that hold
your horses
with the game reaching its climax you
deliver Ellie to her destination like
the reliable FedEx man you are
Joel then learns that Ellie will be
killed in order to save the human race
the same human race that's been trying
to kill you for the past few months so
what do you do undo all your good work
and kidnap Ellie and raise her as your
own daughter she questions your
intentions but we all know she wants you
was their dad too so forget about the
human race was ever done for you guys
race where to me
swear to me that everything that you've
said about the fireflies is true
I swear ok so that was our list have we
missed any how did you feel when you
realize that you were the actual monster
sound off the law if you've enjoyed
wasting time with us please consider
subscribing and help this channel reach
more than 5 people I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade
I'll see you next time